I don't even know if this is gonna work
Jesus Riven key okay I just want to
explain by huh we try to play this game
over a year ago this shoe and we tried
so hard to play this game and I I don't
even know why we tries arcus it doesn't
even look back hey this game is amazing
what are you talking we haven't even
played it yet but yeah I'm sure it's
good it looks amazing there's like a
tomato in a airplane that I'm looking at
anyway uh we're here one year later to
kill play the one and only with and keep
the time I had online and it's just like
a connecting oh damn it I bet you I bet
you my youtube channel this is not gonna
work
yeah it was a strong bet
well that's how I'm sure I am every time
we try to do something it never works
good point
I'm connecting that yeah it's just
connecting what is it connecting to I
don't know I are there actually servers
to connect to or I don't know I'm gonna
turn off my firewall actually oh boy
this game sure is great I'm glad we
waited a year to play this I know me too
are you also still connecting yeah okay
to the googles dad dammit Ruben keep how
to play on holy [ __ ] I am is literally
frozen now I just want to play this game
so bad I know
so wait online is that what I'm gonna
select I guess so online and then as
soon as as soon as we proceed go let's
look so that the planet is to clean it
go at the same time as that yes okay
just so I'm not ready though okay are
you ready
alright one two three go go alright well
here we go
I don't think this is gonna work let's
just pretend this is the game this is
the game so reversion or do you have uh
Dussehra I'm not on the server version
should that make any I'm on at I got it
from the Humble Bundle
there's a humble bundle well mam balonus
or how much was it on the Hubble bundle
store I think it was more expensive oh
no you got ripped off
I got Rick what the heck um on-air
zeroes this is the worst thing that's
ever happened to me is I paid ninety
nine a paid 9.99 well on the sir it's
eight now it's 7.99 what you got you got
ripped off I got ripped off what the
[ __ ] man it's like ah well we can we can
play it I thing god damn it what's
playing without we going with Plan B
let's go to plan B we waited one year
man
I know but obviously it's not good
enough
or we're not good enough for the [ __ ]
knows probably both I don't I'm looking
at [ __ ] all right I have it's kind of
funny how we came further playing online
yeah cuz I remember yeah we actually
were playing oh my god your job
how about we have the same name you
think that would do you want to go back
and try again kind of let's try it again
my name is in cry with load letters Oh
mine was cry [ __ ] no that's too silly I
know obviously the game denied it cuz
it's like candle that [ __ ] yeah
alright just cries all small letters you
ready
hold on hold on small letters I mean
lowercase but I'll do
uh-huh alright three two one go Joe
alright just going to close my eyes and
pretend we're playing together it's so
much fun I just did a backflip oh my god
that was not progressing for to the goal
the graphics are really good man holy
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] yeah next in level this
is looks just like the movie the
labyrinth with David Bowie
what David Boies admin the movie really
no I knew that this is just like that
you know what I was just about to say
that before you said it
oh yeah you know the art style really
brings it in mm-hmm we're not gonna get
us working no we did not
I've been open my eyes now I'm guide
they were open all along all right let's
plan B here
what Lisa ten bucks yeah and like I we
paid for it probably last time too
did you do it I think we did I think so
I want to check if I still have it on my
dessert okay you download what was our
plan B game here
it was either pressure or um okay it's
on its own steam yeah it was apparently
on sale June 5th for $1 no oh and now I
have to spend another $10 why did I why
did I buy with and keep I totally have
it on my Dussehra
yeah damn it I wasted Oh any bucks on
this
maybe it's because you weren't using the
deserver well I was thinking that too
but that sounds silly okay while you
download pressure I'll download this one
we'll give it one more try
don't worry about it I'm installing
DirectX maybe that why it wasn't working
this game I don't think uses DirectX
don't compute no there's no 3d
capabilities in this game hey hey maybe
there's like hidden 3d game underneath
the shirt verge that is like amazing so
like we just like put in a code and then
suddenly it's BAM different game
entirely yeah very pretty awesome this
be like jinx gotcha you thought there
was a shitty game no it's actually
amazing
like this triple a title and I
personally do really like the art style
and stuff
yeah it is I just look like it work all
right you know what I don't know why
we're even bothering with this but okay
I wrote down the name periods do I have
to put it that is my name yes lowercase
yes three two one go it's still
connecting it's not work it's like
connecting all right well oh what the
[ __ ] was it called foul play
let's do a play and it's almost done
downloading can't wait to play this game
mm-hmm all right so the options that I
have is perform or date daemon dare
diary do what I don't know how the hell
do I play online Oh
so how did you join online game all
right
I'll create one in the meanwhile oh okay
it'll be a private match yes but you're
gonna be hosting a game yes you know
what happens in the host games right
you will lag a lot and you'll have to
deal with it [ __ ] I invited you you
should be able to join up did you get my
invite uh yes but taking really really
loud I'm gonna might minx okay hmm good
god turn this game down I'm gonna stop
making noise oh my friends all my
friends are invited now go for a voice
chat on I'm trying that off so that we
don't have that issue oh good you'll
just have to hear me oh great
I don't want to go out now uh I might
only again American yes best game ever
10/10 let's play I have a little mask on
me too this is like [ __ ] real I heard
yeah well I partnered has come on
alright I don't even read it I'm just
going in I'm bold this is I see that mmm
oh this does look at that oh you're not
even reading this story oh oh did you
see that I'm wasn't reading yeah yeah
you got one more to go through it and so
now okay
I thought [ __ ] up what's the story so
far I don't know
I have read my life binding and
banishing the unspeakable and tonight I
have promised to recount these
adventures to you
good I fully intend to you will know
everything I promise you you you may not
thank me for it this is good enough for
you this is great thank you you will see
that mr. scamp wake is that you are you
mr. scamp Rick I think so what am I
gonna do here it was Cairo 1895 and the
British Empire had lost contact entirely
with the dig site
I immediately suspected foul play why oh
my god stay with the game oh my god
alright [ __ ] you know him yeah mister -
fruth it's just a next rise yep yeah I
pressed back I'm sorry are you impressed
oh we can play now wait business is
making a sense I can survive with it I
can do I can do back yeah this is what
we wanted all along I knew it I just
knew you [ __ ] back oh no there's bad
things happen here beautiful this little
thing out of ISM no no dad why would you
bother well I wanted the sword oh oh you
know your icon there you go okay I'll
tell me what to do I did but it's the
hand delivered as promised as shall
expect generous cut you've cute okay
he's hairy you intend to rob us
gentlemen goodness no mister - worth is
that my name I guess so
he doesn't even look at you while he
says it room yeah he's a jerk we intend
to kill you first notice how he's had
his slightly levitating over his head as
well oh he's a magician gee that's all
you know they're legit then loo your
corpses oh god he's freaking he's a
while Raider
why don't they look the other corpses oh
so [ __ ] alright oh [ __ ] I got it I gotta
put my over here classic Whitechapel
tourist trap sir I've checked clocked
earlier what the [ __ ] I suppose we can't
blame the tap we're trying mr. Kemp
I'm point all right let's make this
quick - Fred
yeah please let's make it quick oh I
gained two all right yeah this quick way
back I limbs doing it
no I'm also doing it oh I'm doing it
better I am actually just tickling them
to death I am I don't condone violence
are you not done yet
oh Jesus Jay case I am I don't want guy
oh this guy what is he doing yeah yeah
really gonna oh you got smushed nice oh
good follow the guide strike mister scam
quick it's our only chance of escaping
this blasted sand pet okay what's that
guy doing trying to cycle in the in the
desert that's you're gonna have a bad
time if you do that did you know that
we're on a play stage and we have a big
crowd and they all love our [ __ ] what
look at all the people in the freakin
yeah cuz we're freakin rockin it out
yeah they're like holy [ __ ] violence
it's like a hockey game - the sport
that's sexy - the chick you secondary it
is way too long for me to realize yeah
I'm straight age I don't even know it's
there
oh yeah do you not do hockey in Sweden
no we do hockey it's awesome
oh okay hockey's the [ __ ] and it's the
[ __ ] but I was really tiny when I was
kid so it wasn't that [ __ ] for me uh I
was more more the other [ __ ] I got ska
if you know what I'm saying that's just
depressing [ __ ] I would like to admit
that this is probably one of that
favorite games of my life you know I
would also like to admit this is the
smoothest game that we played together
that is actually I'm supposed to
practice actually works yeah it's
amazing
it's our third resort my favorite part
is how all the hats levitate above the
head it's does I mean I'm a genie as
well uh yes Jean Genie gentlemen you're
okay that makes sense
Rose word for there for a second then I
would some half-assed you we gotta try
not to get hit so I know the mood
ohmmeter oh cool yeah it's like GDR not
DDR it's like
pass the thing up top look at the little
doin a keep the way
oh you're less dead doing it amazing
come here do it
come here okay alright oh there is god
scape wick are there any other
Whitechapel customs we should share with
our good friend again it depends whether
you can also help us all to settle
billiard balls sir okay invaders its
infidels alarm
oh he's not even gonna fight it okay oh
you remember what I taught you about
larger foes mr. scampi do you absolutely
because it's a name for the cross sir
excellent carry on good well I guess we
have to aim for the crotch let's see we
can make the mood of me to go out almost
there it's almost sir don't get hit and
we'll get it oh I don't think we can get
any higher than 400 well no it goes up
you see the stars down there it still
goes up oh that's a thing
yep that's a thing all right and then we
have our image in every okay individual
yes we have our individual bar as well I
don't have you notice I never though all
the night I do yep I just got at a cheap
my guy before you got into a bar okay
don't try to think you were the only one
would you like to look at the score come
on that's is not fair I have a mustache
I need a handicap
I might have one under this little thing
true oh look they're doing the wave in
the audience look at that they're so
high because they like purchase up oh
you're lowering our score they like our
oh come on it's not my fault okay maybe
but actually audience was distracting me
it's not my fault I got stopped loving
the people so much I am so sorry
yeah oh that guy's a banner I'll do this
one I go elves have it
oh my Merrill I sell 4,000 card
oh wait site Oh what the hell what well
where is that guy
I guess he's good hey uh mr. death we're
just gonna miss you right up me is that
your fangirl I don't know
ain't that right mister - freeze oh wait
I'm Lisa - booth miss escape but that
child seems to be in midst of a terrible
fate I reckon is a big fan of you sir
save matil ass mister - birth then have
mr. scamp wiki Kirkman and
unmentionables vegetables hmm above all
things we must win the audience follow
his advice okay so we're just bitter
last we're just [ __ ] catering to our
audience
Jesus you're scaring me okay this is the
perfect game for you what are you
talking an RV buddy don't don't do this
other weird looking [ __ ] fish video
you just did the fish video yeah you
loved it come on don't like it was weird
as [ __ ] dude it made sense if you think
about it did it whoa and that's like a
backstory you'd really have to hauntin
oh I see it so it's got depth to it that
guy just got taken away there wanna be
bold people period Perry Perry Perry
Perry Perry defend yourself missus
cambric you'll get no quarter here okay
huh look at our we're looking at our
meter it's not good enough cry trihard
annex I know it's not even Orange it's
not even Orange that's like come on stop
getting good score come on that's not
fair we got to do it for the audience no
I I'm I don't condone a whoring for the
audience all right it's not my thing
okay now what it's not what I do all
right I understand
Hey look at that guy I know it's an
actual bus I know you might do that [ __ ]
but I understand absolutely
it's just not the way I do things I just
don't get that in my sink low in the
show if you know what I mean you know
what I was gonna say hold but I realized
that was a little offensive so yeah I
don't do that stuff II mean it in the
sense of gardening you got a huge combo
if I get 50 something's gonna happen
I got a magnificent display I don't know
what that means
I don't either I got an achievement
steel to it you're doing so good I know
Wow thank you dude mr. - worth you are
really top form this evening thank you
so much you're welcome
are you gonna charge her my gosh you're
good so I guess you have a mustache I
guess so yeah oh yeah he was off dragger
oops oh my god it seems we have come to
the right place
be cautious follow me Allah hello you're
doing that ninja stance
I don't know if you're nervous lately
I'm a ninja gentlemen wait you're an
angel' lint
ning-ning-ning yell net gentleman ninja
Jen you know what I think you had a
right like four tries ago
Oh thrilling encore bonus oh that was
just an encore
good I have no idea what's going on I
don't either but we got alright and you
were the star performer look at you
performer perfect scene
okay so there's like your coop eyes not
clicked through yet he's an idiot I'm
sorry I don't know it just says it and I
didn't say anything
oh so that was oh okay so there's
another those stages yes I see ha it
says that my core partner is an idiot
I have to say my character kind of looks
like northernlion oh it kind of does
actually and also seems all for
qualified expects a selfie had stolen
all measure of sanity from this man mrs.
cambric yes I intend to find out what ah
do you notice you have a little money
sign on your monocle you're right that's
how you know that's how you know you
mean business
that's you that's the zig this is that
works I just got a big gamble I've
literally just press X on me oh you're
not knocking him up I don't know I just
click eggs and I get good kamma this is
what I swine you can knock him up
what does knock him up mean that and
then you jump up in the combo oh I am
new world for me life is literally yeah
it's an aerial world where you sell -
maybe maybe I can knock over but then
you can get him oh oh oh kick him - no
okay nevermind is the week these guys
these guys are want to be bold people I
don't like that yeah either go bald or
you go look at that we did it how we did
I'm so proud I'm mildly impressed Xbox
record that and you seen a commercial
you know what I'm talking about like the
lamest thing happen ever he's like whoa
Xbox record that you like your franchise
oh yeah let's go
easy lad who did this what are you doing
alone in the desert you have nothing but
I know you probably had friends jump
might keep order god this guy order his
[ __ ] pyramids your I order you not to
die yeah what a [ __ ]
a Friday my monocle money sign is gonna
get in go inflamed soon and that's
waitrons
is that you have a mop I thought it was
a hammer actually that's a boom mic I
believe they're actually right we must
locate this dig side bags missus camp
week I intend to ask general Kane some
questions oh I can't wait to find out
what those questions are I know well see
this is about as much of a story as a
like a legitimate play is so we don't
really get too invested in it you're
just there for the thrill of it all
still a better love story than Twilight
huh
god damn it it's 2014 July 2014 we're
past this I know past this man come on
if you check out all the comments in in
my fish video that's literally all been
really oh my god that's how I learn you
know that's how I stay cool hip and cool
with the kids you know that's how I knew
you're better than that man dude a mr.
Cain's worth you I'm I'm the best I
don't think that's my name it doesn't
matter I have a money money cool oh I
just got it that's genius
[ __ ] can you blow up this channel combo
can I missed it can you let the cattle I
don't think we can I don't have yet to
be able to interact anything in the
stage probably because it's a play and
all these things are just like props
that actually work I wonder how like the
people far to the left if they can still
see anything oh holy [ __ ] how long is
this theater I just realized that it's
this huge it's pretty huge this is like
several football stadium size and it's
our seats are packed I wonder if all the
people on the left are still like
enjoying it or watching it or if they
just went home or some [ __ ] looks like
well are you gone two minutes that was a
great good job got a got our money's
worth
what are how it ended good maybe that's
why they do the wave they'd like do it
to communicate to each other and pie
it's like oh [ __ ] stuff's going on
like God changed those that it's like
it's not like it matters anyway
whoa Wow Wow that was amazing
quirky now what
quirky really quickly scam boy inside
okay well I thought they were our
friends all right this is what I tell
you we're level eight uh I suppose Jesus
crash dead Jesus what happened
general Kane a person I'm the only man
capable of helping you now send your men
down it's still day four they these guys
are like really scared
mad yeah maybe too soon their job they
just want to go home to their wife or
their men's depends yeah that's right
actually we don't get it might be in
that situation where I'd blaze I can't
be in the army if they're homosexual
because that is apparently a deal in
some places well a lot of that might
just be America no no I think there's a
well there's a certain prejudice thing
to it you know you know what having this
discussion at all right now is not a
good decision cuz whatever we say is
gonna end poorly
oh definitely for me at least I'll have
a tumblr post about it tomorrow
don't worry really for you you're you're
a homophobic jerk uh it's cuz I'm bald
probably probably alright don't worry
about it someone's gonna sample you
saying that and just repeat that forever
make a remix of it not let's just go if
I feel like the further we go into this
hey really quick what if it's like it's
very song uh
come on what what happened come on yeah
it's those Arab attacks that you're
doing yeah they're great
attacks cry I hate to lay this out but I
I you know I promised I would
and since in of mine I don't know how
much we can play this or I am insane
it's understandable I think we almost
some of the stage okay let's say states
yes I want to finish I want to know the
story ends def I understand and you know
if the story is really enticing we could
always do this another time yes
the Scarab motive it could it be Al
background that [ __ ] al bra cursor you
know if this video gets 200,000 no wait
500,000 likes will do part to Jesus
Christ that's a huge offer there just
like it and I want at least like five
comments I don't know I don't know this
isn't cool
we're missing a story what I'm sorry I
just can't cut up in my goals of YouTube
I understand this one is right all right
just deal with it I know I know it's all
about the Dodge
not everyone can just have a cute laugh
and get millions of hits all right I
don't even get millions of hits cry it
don't lie to me
alright it's not cool I'm sorry yeah
you're right lying is not just because
you have a homophobic remix doesn't mean
you can get let things get ahead of you
alright
oh yeah I said you're right all right
bad and all right good
I'm liking this this is where's the
[ __ ] boss I don't know it's not coming
this is endless waves of soldiers but
they're all scared Merrill they're
they're terrified Jesus come on look at
that soldier in the back look at the guy
in the back I can't see cuz you're
freaking combo is all over the place
he's shot you try to shoot me he's just
hiding over there he looks scared but
then he came you came over there oh I'm
gonna get you no wait can you know
oh I don't yeah look at the health bar
up there oh I thought that was coming
hey crane hi what are you trying to
touch there
what let's say that what is it your job
guys what are you do we gotta do
something for the transmission no the
most good mood is growing trust me
listen if Andy ends the audience goddamn
it alright we got a good audience
doesn't know what they like
alright sometimes you think you have to
disobey what they want what is he doing
he just disappeared behind it
oh he's having a little bit of an issue
back it's coming alright it's coming
right Oh God yeah okay thank God thank
God yes good
oh thank god yeah I'll see you for the
throne read this one that's you it's
very hurry oh all right look it's the
boss it is device oh we gotta do
something funny sound like um I'll go
over here see if there's something over
here I feel like there's something we
got to do when he's down oh no nobody's
losing help for Karis money he is but
alright just goes down like an outcry
I'm vanadium Oh everyone light like
usually they're vulnerable and when they
do that yeah it's kind of weird it's
like ah crap ease down we gotta be
gentlemen and not actually hit him yeah
well actually we are yes be honest
you're right [ __ ]
alright cool attack my shout cry let's
please expresses I don't know what would
happen if look at his thing I love his
selfie at the background i don't know
why i don't know why i call it selfie i
kind of hit me a little bit for
goodnight
those have been around since before the
was even a term opens late hey whatchu
who did it sounds a little bit snobby
back then you gotta be seen anyone from
a his story they did it on accident I
action what a Google is just to find out
god it's almost dead he is feeling it
that's for sure
feeling it good it's Philly
right he's just like the Fiat element
there oh he kill oh my god that's deep
man word man I can't wait
you know what waits in the city cane and
it's no so no no I really a sure what am
i good cap yeah do it ah look at that
he's gonna like our fame yeah more fame
than me crying this is like AA meeting
Jesus don't let it get to your head
come knelt under I guess I get the
YouTube channel Popeye calm yeah it's
yours now enjoy it this was fun indeed
oh well you had to hurry to go back to
the cinema what wait no no no we were
doing that whilst you were having to
hurry to go to the cinema yes yes we did
it so it's a pretty smooth as long as
you have a plan B and a C you're you're
all good to go
you're right I do an outro or something
say something inspirational this is a
water bottle